let's go next to
james in cambridge
hey david can you hear me all right i
can hear you find james
hi uh first i was wondering um you said
something in a show um i think about a
week ago about um
that it's um it's a myth that the united
states uh ever promised um
gorbachev or anyone that nato wouldn't
expand eastwards and i was just
wondering where you had read that
because uh because i've just read some
things that are contradictory so i was
just kind of curious about that i i
don't remember the specific source but
my understanding of the story was that
it was verbally offered as a concession
at one point in negotiations but that it
was subsequently removed at the
direction of uh
u.s and i believe
german dignitaries and it was never
codified or signed anywhere and actually
made an agreement
okay okay i just want a clarification on
that because i had just seen some
transcripts from uh george washington
university
that described as you said that it was
verbally promised um and my second
question
um which is more to do with trump is
why is it that trump is often portrayed
as a populist because first of all the
bulk of his support actually came from
higher income people yes and secondly uh
his policies
were incredibly beneficial to the rich
for my estimation he's one of the most
elitist presidents in american history
so your conclusion is correct he's one
of the most elitist i don't i don't know
that it's accurate to say the bulk of
his support came from high income people
is it possible what you meant is high
income people supported him more than
hillary is that maybe that's what you
meant
um um yeah yeah um i i to reword what i
said on average in 2016 and 2020
the average income of his supporters was
higher than the average income of either
of the democratic nominees okay now
remember if average means mean that
could not be a super useful metric but
let's not even concern ourselves with
that because your main point is a good
one which is about policy yes trump has
been a was an incredibly elitist
president the tax reform plan
disproportionately benefited the the
very wealthy um and the things he
promised to do for middle-income people
lower-income people he didn't do and um
i don't know why he was called the
populist i mean there's two perspectives
on that one is that he's a right-wing
populist others would say right-wing
populism doesn't actually exist he just
used populist rhetoric but he's not
actually a populist it becomes more of a
semantic debate but the conclusion's the
right one trump was one of the most
pro-elitist presidents we've had
yeah he also uh destroyed a lot of labor
regulations um that um that especially
in covid were really disastrous yeah um
i would actually say that people like
aoc and bernie sanders are
more
are legitimately populist in terms of
policy substance and anybody like trump
or uh joshua or josh holly i agree with
you 100 percent
so yeah uh uh thanks for uh thanks for
taking my call david thank you oh and
then the left a little prematurely there
but that's okay
um let's go next where where are we
going next how about uh
how about jason in atlanta jason you're
on the air
hi david uh calling because i was
wondering uh you have
in the past mentioned support for a uh
shorter work week um
first of all how many hours do you think
would be ideal i know keane's predicted
by 2030 we'd have a 15-hour work week
yeah the the the per the prediction from
keynes uh has not is an old prediction
he predicted that as technology
increased productivity people would
basically have mostly time for leisure
um
and
you know it's it's an old prediction
that turned out not not to be right and
there's a lot of different reasons why
i have not devoted a lot of time to the
number of hours that i think is the i
think it's different in different
industries and different types of jobs
in particular there are jobs where you
quite literally
are selling your labor an hour at a time
and so if you reduce the number of hours
in order to keep the same compensation
your hourly rate needs to go up and
that's very different for someone
working at mcdonald's versus someone who
is like a lawyer or a therapist that is
compensated hourly but has more control
over their wage so for me it's less
about that i don't have the answers to
that but
i've been very supportive of the idea
that the bulk of our work can easily be
condensed into four days in a lot of
information type jobs i want to be
really clear about that
and at the show
we condense production of our five
weekly shows
into
four days um so number of hours i don't
know
[Music]
different industries different answers
but i think much of how work is
organized is not super efficient in
terms of providing the most leisure time
okay yeah thank you and you kind of are
you answered what my next question was
going to be which was how we would make
up for the um
lost income because if you know most
people are working hourly if they get
their hours cut they would uh by making
less money right with salaried workers
if you
become
more
inspired and more efficient by knowing
that your work week is shorter and you
kind of get the same amount of work done
you could say that takes care of itself
there are some who say well we don't
really need as much efficiency as we
actually get it would be okay if we were
not quite as a fit there's really a lot
of different opinions about that but for
the hourly worker who you know if you go
to someone who makes 15 bucks an hour
working
nine to five monday through friday and
you say great news you now only work
monday through thursday if you don't
make any other change you've taken
twenty percent of their income
right yeah
i don't have an answer very much yeah
thanks jason from atlanta very very
important question